Ouija boards you do not open up portals
for anything to come through when you
can't control what's coming through so
even with what I do I have dead
University I'm the headmistress of dead
University so I I'm the professor of
mediumship and when I talk to them about
this a lot of people with abilities have
weak borders and boundaries and so
they're all they're often overwhelmed by
mischievous entities that are sort of
messing with weak Minds is the way I
would put it so the reason the other
side comes through to children so often
is because they have weak borders and
boundaries and they're usually pretty
gentle so the other side's really drawn
to children but also people who do have
mental health issues have weak minds and
weak borders and boundaries so that can
be a problem for those people or
somebody who
has kind of suicidal energy if they have
that tone to them sort of more of a low
frequency energy they're going to draw
in low frequency energy from the other
side so you sort of draw in what you put
out
energy wise which we all know in the
dating world you draw in what you put
out so you have to be really careful
about what you put out
yeah yeah always gotta check yourself on
that one it's not really their fault
it's your fault I've had to go through a
lot of therapy to learn that that's so
funny I was always the
um it's not me it's you person
so was I that's why I drew in his super
confident guy
I just liked messing with the guys you
know like I'm like I don't need you I I
was more of the I was more like a dude
when I was out there in the dating world
so I really didn't care about getting
married or and you know having kids or
any of that so I just made myself a
tractor beam every guy wants to hear
that they're like no it's you're like a
hard one to get yeah yeah and that that
worked because I got the ungettable guy
who got the ungettable girl and that
worked out
I mean I was the opposite I'm like let's
get married tomorrow
[Laughter]
sweet though that's really sweet how do
they know if there's someone with a weak
boundary that's a good question so with
what I do especially because anything
could come through I actually tell the
other side what I want so if for
instance somebody who died comes through
two hours before a reading and I'm
making cupcakes for my daughter's school
that happened once when she was younger
and I said to him I said not now I said
you have a two o'clock at two o'clock
I'm all yours but right now
I'm not gotta go and so they sort of
fade then and then they'll come back but
I established a border and a boundary
with the other side people who play with
Ouija boards are opening it up and have
no borders and boundaries that's why
they're playing with a Ouija board in
the first place you know seeing what
will come through they just they're
doing it more for entertainment but
mischievous entities can attach to you
and they're also very alive and well
these mischievous entities in hospitals
so I often tell nurses doctors people
police officers people who spend a lot
of time around mental health or health
facilities there are certain things you
need to do to make sure you detach so
when you leave a hospital for instance
there are people that died that didn't
know that they died
so they'll try to talk to you and sort
of get in the car with you and you start
making all these wrong turns on the road
it's because something has attached
itself to you because it's looking for
somebody to listen do you actually see
them is our is it like they're in the
passenger seat like as if they're like
hey will you take me home I and they get
in and like but they're actually just an
energy they're just sometimes sometimes
it's seeing them completely uh it takes
less energy for them to show themselves
to you in your mind it takes a lot more
of their energy to project themselves
completely so it just depends on what
they need and want but they get
frustrated that their families left and
wouldn't hear them that they were okay
that they're still here again they don't
know they've passed so they're just
trying to get somebody's attention they
don't usually mean any harm but
sometimes those people died and they
were schizophrenic or there was
something going on with them and that
goes away when the body goes away but
the energy still can be a little screwy
until they adjust on the other side so
that's something people need to be aware
of and you for instance if somebody's a
sensitive and they come in contact with
bad energy you know if everybody's been
somewhere where they meet somebody or
they are in the sphere of somebody and
feel
a molestation energy sometimes you feel
like there's just something like they
shouldn't look at children in the
grocery store and you're kind of keeping
an eye on that person or you pick up a
really dark Vibe like they're a liar or
that they cheat you know something that
you're picking up on them that's
repelling to you because it's not your
energy it's not the same as your energy
so when when that happens for you you
need to make sure you go home whether
you take a bath or a shower I call it a
baptism down the drain away from me and
I visualize what I came into contact
with how it made me feel whether it be
somebody you love that has cancer and
you want to let go of that energy and
the cancers going down the drain away
from you the pain is going down the
drain away from you and you say it three
times and you visualize it going down a
long pipe until it disappears and I do
this every time I do a reading or have
worked a murder or just come in contact
with somebody I never want to come into
contact with again so that happens a lot
it does I'm an aquarius we sort of keep
to ourselves
but your electric eclectic energy
probably attracts a lot of interesting
folk yeah
um it's the hair I think but yeah for
sure just because I'm an unusual toy
they want to come and talk to me so when
I'd be on an airplane flying to a book
signing somebody would ask me what I'd
what I'd do and I just say I'm a
secretary
and then they stopped talking to you it
was perfect I'm a secretary to the dead
so it's not a lie I just came up with a
way to make it okay for me and for them
to go away yeah
are some of the energies of this planet
are they human does anything ever come
through that's not human
um I've had a a couple of interactions
with angels which don't feel human okay
actually
um it was in protection for me so I felt
very safe but they they aren't like
these sweet cherubinis they were
actually sort of their wings were more
like
Shields and they stand they were
standing shoulder to shoulder with their
back to my I was in my cabin at the time
by myself trying to finish my third book
at the time and it was scary it was
Winter nobody was in the White Mountain
summer homes it was just me and I was
all alone and so it scared me and I felt
something bad something dangerous at
just outside and so I closed my eyes and
then I saw them standing around sort of
in protection and I knew I didn't have
to worry and they just stayed right
there and it was more of a feeling of
comfort a feeling that I was safe but
that I should fear them because they
weren't weak you know there's something
about them that was very strong stronger
than any human could be and it was very
intense this is the best way that I
could describe what that energy was like
it's almost as if they communicate
telepathically yeah you know what their
intention is you know
um that they don't mean you any harm but
you also know that they're no doormat
you know these These are these are
warriors so I found that very
interesting and eye-opening
How does the energy come through to you
because when you said it's like a you
just it's a knowing
um that's for me how it feels when I get
other dimensional energies or
information like it it comes into my
awareness right
um so I'm curious like how it comes
through for you
um how do you see it or hear it or feel
it or know it like what's your Claires
how many Claires do you have
so for me when I'm having communication
whether it be the dead or Angels they
are telepathic they can communicate
without they'll make you feel something
they make they'll show you Visions or
um walk you through a scene as though it
were a clip from a movie they
communicate in any way that they can
through our own senses and what we have
to offer also our own vocabulary Banks
and sense of knowledge I also can hear
them sometimes they just speak out loud
and they'll yell in my ear and I'll just
repeat what they say to my client like I
said I'm just a secretary to the dead
that's really all I am and I repeat what
they say to my client and
um and that's they communicate with
however much energy they want it or can
expel it all depends on how much energy
they have people who lived stronger
lives you know connected with more
people loved big took risks you know you
would be easy to bring through because
you have an energy that exudes it's like
Beyond you know almost where sometimes
and I think it's why people see famous
people on this pedestal because they
they emit this light or project this
energy and people are drawn to it
because a lot of people have low
frequency energy so they sort of feed
off of your energy if you like this clip
and you want to hear the whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen